in case you didn't know there's a new
pewdiepie rhinoshield clan
with 10 new exclusive designs these ones
are probably my favorite we got the new
neon city bam we got the japanese wave
we went for a japanese aesthetic on
these beautiful and the one i have of
course pewdiepie ninja soda so one of
the cool things about runner shield out
of many is that you can mix and match
and really make the phone feel yours you
can customize the button change the rim
whatever you want they can do it if
there's a color you like rhino shield
has it and of course we don't just have
the new designs which i recommend we
also have the classics classic wave
comes in 20 different colors and you can
add letters to really make it yours as
well which i like i really like this one
too because it's it's very subtle only
shows in a different the right kind of
light so cool i'm pairing my rhino
shield with the screen protector
which basically makes it completely
indestructible it turns your phone into
the old nokia completely indestructible
i've tested this i stand by this it's
amazing
if you care about your phone you need to
have it and rhino shield is is the best
we also have the wave in a bunch of
different colors they've done collabs
with snoopy van gogh league of legends
arcane and many others and if that
wasn't enough they ship worldwide bam if
that wasn't enough free shipping for
qualified order boom baby
you're not convinced yet oh lifetime
warranty bazinga
they're available for all iphone
flagship android flagship devices now is
the perfect time to gift yourself or a
friend and if all of this wasn't enough
to convince you if you use the code
pewdiepie you get 20 off in the first
week only then it goes to 10 off so you
still make sure to use the code but make
sure you jump on this offer because it
doesn't get better than this link is in
the description i love this product
they're great i think you like them too
that's enough for me selling you [ __ ]
i'm sorry but they're legitimately good
so on with the video thank you ryan
shiel
blurst today we're taking a look at
blurs images the most wonderful images
ever
basically things that shouldn't exist i
don't know
i don't know what the quality is all i
know
is that
i love it
blurs point of view
oh the more i look at it the better it
gets beautiful blurs super suit ain't
nothing blurs about that that's
beautiful blurs pizza where's your god
now oh they put
oh no no
well at least you know the pizzas
doesn't have any crusts on it so i do
think that's a win why would you
this one i don't like download this one
please
the thing is me and marcia have this as
our wedding god damn it
[Laughter]
no
no stop it downloading this stop it with
the blurs wait what am i looking at ah
[Music]
that's illegal
i didn't realize i was looking at as
much birds nesting on top of a security
camera
that's beautiful
blurs gentleman leaves his
sweater his pants as a scarf his
underwear as an umbrella
and his sock as a door handle wow
i think this is the thing yeah
that isn't a dress for men i was
actually thinking about a business idea
that i had where guys always have to
hand out their jackets to the woman
right unwritten rule oh i'm a little bit
cold
i should have brought a jacket
here we go you can have my jacket it's
okay my business plan is this
a jacket
that becomes two jackets double jacket
it's genius i think it could take off we
could branch out to anything it'll be
called my girlfriend forgot to bring uh
that's what the company is called we'll
do jackets umbrellas uh
anyway just uh just a random thought
oh god you've ruined those
hey
oh god that's worse than my fortnite
tattoo i can't believe it
or a hamster so funny i want a hamster
now i don't want a hamster but
[Music]
come on look at this thing
a hamster looks like it has a minus iq
love i love the things
when you're doing zoom classes but you
forgot to turn the camera
[Music]
yeah i just want to talk about mind
control
uh it's so awful oh is that yeah
yeah ken ken and i reacted to this guy's
channel they're amazing oh someone
filmed him
let's go
oh god you don't with the armies
i gotta subscribe to that whistling
diesel
cute shout out so [ __ ] funny oh my
god oh my god
oh my god no stop ah
spider-man fans
are in tears they're crying
how are you gonna explain this one
spider-man fans hey
tom holland isn't spiderman is it the
guy from lillian's stage no wait the guy
from ice age holy [ __ ] i knew it wait
does this apply everywhere all right
here we have tom holland a perfectly
dispropor uh proportionate face
oh bro it does not match at all
there we go
the tomahawk to fit the spiderman mask
he would have to look like i'm just
saying i'm nothing wrong
yeah it's proven spider-man fans are in
tears anyway happy birthday it's a cake
it's an iphone it has an apple in it why
would you do that
fixed it fix the moral dilemma for you
even a child could figure it out
yeah this kind of feels like a boomer
meme am i like am i laughing at boomer
comics what is happening
[Laughter]
everyone is beautiful on the inside
people on the inside
oh god more boomers i like it what stop
it
someone made this it's a child picking
his nose the nose finds the booger it
dug too deep and it gets uh
nice why did someone think about this
why did someone draw this why am i
watching it why are you watching it
is it gonna hit the corner come on
oh god
stop
please
ah god and the pain
[Music]
the photo isn't funny but the caption is
blood are so sad
damn it's up minecraft
guys stop stop i said stop with
minecraft i said stop it stop it effects
are pretty good i like it i like it a
lot in fact nice
some things never change that's
wonderful
what a nice wholesome image
i mean if you have two kids it kind of
makes sense right this baby's lacking
loaded
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
no crocodiles don't have feelings
are you serious
this is not real florida
flock he is a federally licensed
emotional support alligator
alligator we'll go have fun today huh oh
my god i got your tail i don't want to
imagine life without wally
emotional support alligator well when we
take wally places we don't charge a
place we ask for donations and i've been
feeding hungry for over 15 years that's
my reward cheering people up
oh he's so passionate about it good old
wally uh
uh merry christmas guys
alternate universe christmas be like
oh my god that can't be legal
[Music]
that's so irritating
i hate it stop it
damn it
yeah i got it
oh god
goofy draw goofy yeah that's the thing
that's kind of blurs the fact that goofy
is a dog but he also has pluto which is
a dog too what does that all about huh
explain yourself disney we want answers
god damn it hello
yes
thank you
god there needs to be another business
idea have someone a small person that
smells people if they smell they have to
buy deodorant at an ups up cost right
just like they do at airports it's
genius oh sorry sir you smell don't
worry we'll discreetly put on deodorant
just buy our anti
stink package only 50 and you can enter
that's smart i like that idea
[Music]
spoilers
damn
no chill huh
sure you're not bernie another blurs tom
holland
why why is this a photo
look at how
oh my god that's so good i kind of want
it what
all right i've been doing this too much
i i always like this if you enjoy them
as well smash like subscribe and you
could win a billion happy merry
christmas to you all have a great
holidays happy holidays from the
pewdiepie family goodbye hey dude bro
fish